♪ ♪ ♪
- L'eau de la baie de Fundy
est à 4 °C, rien pour empêcher
Michel Cormier d'y plonger.
Depuis 1992, il est mordu
de plongée sous-marine.
MICHEL CORMIER,
plongeur et pêcheur de pétoncle
- J'étais comme, on dirait,
hooké. Donc, tous les hivers,
on revenait. En 1992, à cette
époque-là, il n'y avait presque
personne qui venait ici.
- Aujourd'hui, ils sont
une dizaine sur la plage
de Saint-George, près de Deer
Island. Diane et Serge Cormier,
propriétaires d'une école
de plongée, remarquent eux
aussi l'intérêt grandissant
non seulement pour la plongée,
mais pour pêcher le mollusque.
SERGE CORMIER,
copropriétaire, "La Dive shop"
- Il y a des personnes,
des plongueurs qui vont
appeler : "La prochaine plongée
de pétoncles que vous allez
faire, est-ce qu'on pourrait
aller avec vous autres?"
Puis là, on les invite,
il y a deux nouveaux plongeurs
qui sont venus aujourd'hui.
♪ ♪ ♪
DIANE CORMIER,
copropriétaire, "La Dive shop"
- Au début, tu entres
dans l'eau, l'eau est...
elle est froide.
C'est un petit choc au début.
"La première" pétoncle que
tu trouves, t'oublies tout
le mal, puis tu ramasses.
Ça fait des belles pêches.
- Parmi les pétoncles
se trouvent notamment
oursins et étoiles de mer : un
véritable spectacle sous-marin.
- À chaque fois qu'on vient,
on se surprend puis on en
trouve, puis on en trouve...
Aujourd'hui, on avait...
on a pogné notre quota,
on a notre permis, 100 pétoncles
par jour par plongeur.
- "It's quite a lot of work."
- La pêche récrétative
aux pétoncles existe depuis plus
de 100 ans, mais ce n'est que
depuis le milieu des années 80
qu'elle est réglementée.
Les demandes de permis
sont stables depuis cinq ans :
autour de 1500. Contrairement
à d'autres espèces, les stocks
de pétoncles sont en très bonne
santé en Atlantique.
Et selon Pêches et Océans
Canada, il n'y aurait pas
de tensions entre les pêcheurs
commerciaux et les amateurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et une fois à l'extérieur
de l'eau, l'expérience visuelle
devient aussi gustative.
- Très "grosse" pétoncle!
♪ ♪ ♪
(rire)
- (Maude Montembeault):
C'est bon?
- Hmm! C'est très bon.
- Une livre des plus gros
pétoncles peut se vendre
jusqu'à 28 $ en poissonnerie.
Ce soir, c'est la femme
de Michel qui profitera
avec lui de sa récolte.
- À soir, je sais pas.
Probablement dans le four avec
un peu de bacon puis peut-être
même un petit peu de sirop
d'érable. Délicieux!
- S'il accepte de donner
sa recette, Michel reste
cependant secret sur ses autres
repaires de pêche.
Ici Maude Montembeault,
Radio-Canada, Saint-George.